Новини дня «heute» з Яною Парайґіс.
Вітаємо вас цього вечора п'ятниці в нашому ефірі.
Про поразку Звєрєва у півфіналі
чемпіонату з тенісу трохи згодом розповість
Норберт Леман у новинах спорту.
А зараз погляньмо на головні теми
сьогоднішнього випуску.
Велика аварія поїзда
поблизу Гарміш-Партенкірхена:
регіональний потяг зійшов з рейок,
чотири людини загинули, 30 - отримали поранення.
100 днів війни в Україні:
російська армія майже захопила
всю Луганську область.
Важливі голосування:
Бундестаг ухвалив рішення про створення
спеціального фонду на 100 млрд євро
на потреби Збройних сил Німеччини
та підвищення мінімальної
заробітної плати на 12 євро.
На початку святкових днів на Трійцю в Баварії
зійшов з рейок регіональний експрес.
Унаслідок аварії загинуло щонайменше 4 людини,
30 - отримали поранення,
15 з них госпіталізовані.
Канцлер Шольц і прем'єр-міністр Баварії Зедер
висловили співчуття
родичам загиблих і пораненим.
Досі триває масштабна рятувальна операція.
Потяг прямував
з Гарміш-Партенкірхена до Мюнхена.
Незабаром після відправлення кілька вагонів
зійшли з рейок на ділянці колії
поблизу села Бурґрайн.
Сибіла Басслер розкаже більше.
Довкола блукають шоковані люди.
Нещодавно тут зійшов з рейок регіональний потяг,
який їхав з Гарміш-Партенкірхена до Мюнхена.
Кілька вагонів перекинулися на бік,
деякі - впали на узбіччя.
Щонайменше 4 людини загинули,
багато пасажирів отримали травми.
Причина аварії поки невідома.
Слідчі вже збирають перші дані, щоб
згодом якнайшвидше з'ясувати причини аварії.
На місці працюють багато
пожежників, медиків, а також поліція.
Уже за п'ять хвилин після екстреного виклику
на місце аварії прибули перші рятувальники.
На борту регіонального поїзда були солдати
Бундесверу, які одразу допомогли рятувальникам.
Вони дуже допомогли нам,
зокрема витягувати людей через вікна.
За допомогою рятувальної техніки працівники
служб екстреної допомоги змогли врятувати
травмованих пасажирів, зокрема важкопоранених.
На жаль, серед постраждалих є діти.
Поранених доставили до найближчих лікарень.
Слідчі припускають, що є й інші жертви.
На жаль, є ймовірність, що під завалами
ми знайдемо ще більше загиблих.
Роботи на місці аварії
поблизу Бурґрайна тривали й ввечері.
З нами на зв'язку з місця аварії Ютта Зонневальд.
Як проходить рятувальна операція
і що нового вдалося дізнатися
про залізничну катастрофу?
Рятувальникам вдалося врятувати
з-під уламків усіх постраждалих пасажирів.
Загалом загинуло чотири пасажири,
одна людина померла на шляху до лікарні.
Повідомляють, що ще принаймні три людини
перебувають під уламками.
Щоб їх врятувати, рятувальникам
необхідно підняти ці неймовірно важкі вагони.
Ще не вдалося з'ясувати причини катастрофи.
Поліція виключає можливість зіткнення потягів,
адже ця ділянка одноколійна
та не має стрілочних переводів.
Машиніст потяга вижив. Він перебуває в лікарні,
проте інформація щодо його стану відсутня.
Місцевий диктор залізниці зазначив, що машиніст
не їхав на червоний попереджувальний сигнал.
Це все, що наразі відомо.
Робота спеціальної слідчої групи триває.
З нами була Ютта Зонневальд. Дякую.
А зараз погляньмо на ситуацію в Україні.
Минуло рівно 100 днів
з початку повномасштабної війни.
Досі важко підрахувати
точну кількість жертв війни.
Наразі ООН підтвердила загибель
щонайменше 4100 мирних жителів.
Однак Управління Верховного
комісара ООН з прав людини
повідомляє про значно вищі цифри.
Нині активні бої тривають
переважно на Сході країни.
Наш репортер з місця подій
надасть нам оцінку ситуації за 100 днів війни.
Але спочатку пригадаймо минулі події.
Наступ російських військ
(території позначено
темно-помаранчевим кольором)
розпочався 24 лютого, лінія фронту була широкою.
Українці змогли дати відсіч запланованому
швидкому наступу на Київ.
Росія відступила на початку квітня
й змінила стратегію, концентруючи зусилля
на Сході та Півдні.
Маріуполь чинив героїчний спротив до травня,
коли його зрештою захопили.
Наразі російська армія повільно
просувається на території Донбасу.
Про це більше розповість Пабло Зілагалі.
Вони демонструють свою силу на танках -
російські бійці в Луганській області,
яка наразі майже повністю
перебуває під їхнім контролем.
Московські війська продовжують просуватися.
Особливо важкі бої точаться
за місто Сєвєродонецьк.
Повідомляють, що на території
місцевого хімзаводу
ховаються сотні мирних жителів.
Українським військовим
допомагають захищати місто
іноземні легіонери.
Британська розвідка припускає, що Росія
незабаром захопить весь Донбас.
Посол України в Німеччині
не хоче з цим миритися.
Ба більше, він обстоює ідею повернення Криму.
Ми ніколи не відмовимося від Криму,
у цьому сумнівів немає.
Питання в тому, коли ми його повернемо.
Ми тверезо оцінюємо ситуацію.
Ми бачимо, яку перевагу має Росія
в цій загарбницькій війні на знищення.
Російська армія використовує
100-й день загарбницької війни як символ:
вона оприлюднює ці кадри
з самохідними гаубицями
й великою кількістю боєприпасів.
Так вони повідомляють про те,
що готові воювати й надалі.
Символи бачимо й у Києві.
У центрі міста
виставили трофейну російську військову техніку.
Президент упевнений у майбутній перемозі.
Захищаємо Україну вже 100 днів.
Перемога за нами. Слава Україні!
100 днів війни.
Зеленський стверджує, що за цей час
загинули десятки тисяч людей.
Зокрема в Маріуполі кладовища вже занадто малі.
Тисячі загиблих, тисячі доль,
проте на могилах здебільшого
навіть немає імен. Лише номери.
В Україні перебуває наш репортер Йоганнес Гано.
Україна впевнена у своїй перемозі,
але якщо подивитися на ситуацію збоку,
то як можна її оцінити за 100 днів війни?
Звичайно, президент Зеленський знає,
що він зобов'язаний дати своїм громадянам
саме таку відповідь, тому що люди
прагнуть перемогти в цій війні.
Ніхто не може уявити поразку,
адже Маріуполь, Буча, Ірпінь
уже показали, що буде, якщо Росія переможе,
а саме тотальне знищення українців як нації,
тож люди роблять усе, щоб не допустити цього.
Президент також сказав, що в цій війні
неможливо перемогти
без потрібної зброї.
Саме тому він постійно тисне
на західних союзників, мовляв,
для перемоги необхідна важка зброя й ППО.
І хоча бракує зброї, та не бойового духу.
На 100-й день війни люди досі готові боротися
і хочуть якнайшвидше
прогнати росіян зі своєї землі.
Йоганнес Гано з нами
на зв'язку з України. Щиро дякую.
Відучора голова Верховної Ради України
Руслан Стефанчук перебуває в Берліні з візитом.
Сьогодні він зустрівся з канцлером Шольцом.
Пізніше у відомстві канцлера назвали
їхні перемовини «дуже приємною розмовою».
Про зміст переговорів нічого не відомо.
Проте, як повідомляють, Стефанчук запросив
Шольца до Києва.
Той «взяв до уваги» це запрошення, так зазначає
представник уряду.
Поки не відомо, чи плануватиметься така поїздка.
Росія заблокувала українські порти,
і тепер країна не можна експортувати зерно.
Наслідки цього відчувають у всьому світі.
Сьогодні Чад уже оголосив надзвичайну ситуацію,
пов'язану з продовольчою кризою.
Президент Африканського Союзу Макі Салл
здійснив візит до президента Росії Путіна в Сочі
й закликав припинити блокаду.
Про побоювання щодо
можливої продовольчої катастрофи
розповість Лютен Ляйнгос.
Україна - це родючі ґрунти,
багаті врожаї, житниця Європи.
Нині там вирує війна.
Тепер урожай бути значно біднішим.
Однак найбільшого краху зазнає експорт зерна.
Припускають, що наразі
в Україні заблоковано понад 20 млн тонн зерна.
Їх можна було б експортувати,
але вони залишаються на території України,
тому що Росія блокує порти.
Найбільше зерна застрягло тут, в Одесі,
безумовно, найважливішому порту
для експорту зерна з України.
Наслідки для забезпечення харчами світу
можуть бути руйнівними.
Досі Україна забезпечувала зерном
велику частину світу.
Густонаселені країни, як-от Єгипет та Індонезія,
особливо залежать від українського зерна.
Насправді нам загрожує
крах систем харчового забезпечення,
адже ці наслідки, зокрема скорочення експорту
й накопичення запасів, нагромаджуються,
і багато країн,
які залежать від імпорту,
більше не можуть собі його дозволити.
Єгипет, населення якого складає
близько 100 млн жителів,
вже зараз значно відчуває ці наслідки.
Країна намагається терміново
збільшити обсяги власного врожаю.
Африка залежить від пшениці з України й Росії
особливо сильно.
Крім того, через кризу,
спричинену пандемією COVID-19,
резерви багатьох країн уже геть вичерпані.
Через це все вже є можливість,
що нам доведеться побачити жахливі кадри
багатьох людей, яким нема що їсти
або які й зовсім помирають з голоду.
Перша спроба послабити блокаду портів
має відбутися наступного тижня.
Наступного тижня Туреччина й Росія планують
обговорювати можливе відкриття
коридору для експорту зерна з України.
Блокада українського експорту харчів -
це одна з головних тем у розділі «ZDFheute live»
о 19:30 у застосунку «ZDFheute»,
на Youtube та Facebook.
Занепалі Збройні сили й брак грошей на ремонт:
ймовірно, всьому цьому прийде кінець.
Після довгих вагань Бундестаг
проклав дорогу
історичним змінам, які обіцяв канцлер Шольц.
Двома третинами голосів було ухвалено
«Спеціальний фонд Бундесверу» на 100 млрд євро
для вельми довгого списку покупок:
від винищувачів-«невидимок»
до чобіт для військових.
Також парламент підтримав інвестування 50,4 млрд євро
з регулярного бюджету на 2022 рік.
Детальніше про це - у репортажі Девіда Ґебгарда.
Шольц робить свій вибір.
Здається, у канцлера не було сумнівів, що пропозицію
підтримає абсолютна більшість парламентарів.
Шольц вважає збільшення озброєння Бундесверу
епохальною подією.
Роками панували
безгосподарність і дефіцит:
гелікоптери, що не літають, підводні човни, що не плавають,
недостатнє спорядження.
Навіть військовослужбовці найвищих рангів повідомляли
про незадовільний стан Бундесверу.
Тож час покласти цьому кінець:
занедбання та спустошення Бундесверу
тривало десятиліттями.
Я постійно чую: цього у нас немає,
а іншого занадто мало.
Це вже вийшло з ладу, а оте - зламане.
Це має припинитися.
Щоб внести законопроєкт про спеціальний фонд
до Конституції ФРН,
«світлофорній» коаліції необхідно залучитися
підтримкою Союзу CDU/CSU.
Партія Зелених хотіла інвестувати частину фонду
у кібербезпеку,
але Союз виступив проти.
Зелені відмовилися від своїх намірів
інвестувати кошти в інші сфери, в інші міністерства
та на інші завдання. Відмовилися.
Мене дуже розсмішило те, що Ви,
пане Добриндте, сказали, нібито тільки ми
нічого не робили.
Якщо Ви так хотіли потішити своє его, то будь ласка.
100 млрд спеціального фонду - це фактично нові
борги.
Цей фонд
створений на основі дозволу на запозичення.
На цьому критичному етапі кращих альтернатив
не знайти.
Нам не потрібні зміни до Конституції ФРН,
щоб інвестувати кошти в Бундесвер.
Якщо партія AfD критикує такий тип
фінансування спеціального фонду,
та партія Лівих критикує сам факт інвестування
коштів у Бундесвер.
Бундесвер страждає не від нестачі фінансування,
а від бездумного розпоряджання податковими коштами.
Якими спочатку невміло розпоряджався коштами
міністр Союзу, а зараз - партії SPD. Це і є причина!
У списку потрібних речей: винищувачі,
сучасні радіоприймачі та навіть черевики.
Очікується збільшення інвестування
в оборонну промисловість країни.
Бундестаг ухвалив й інші законопроєкти.
З першого липня відбудеться підвищення
пенсійних виплат: на Заході - на 5,35%,
на Сході - на 6,12%.
Гарна новина для тих, хто займається підробітком:
з жовтня очікується підвищення межі доходів
з 450 до 520 євро.
Зокрема, з першого жовтня на 12 євро
зросте мінімальна зарплата.
За це проголосували коаліція та партія Лівих.
Союз і партія AfD утрималися.
Конфедерація німецьких асоціацій роботодавців
повідомляє про «напад на тарифну автономію»,
адже зазвичай обсяг мінімальної зарплати
визначали роботодавці та профспілки.
SPD, ухвалюючи підвищення мінімальної зарплати
на 12 євро,
виконує одну з передвиборчих обіцянок.
Брітта Шпікерман розповість більше.
Команда перукарів Штефані Шпер у салоні
в центрі Берліна.
Це важкі часи.
Спочатку коронавірус, тепер інфляція.
Тож керівниця радіє підвищенню
мінімальної зарплати.
Мені дуже важливо, щоб моя робота
належно оплачувалася.
І мені до вподоби,
що тепер мінімальна заробітна плата фіксована.
Законопроєкт розробив
Міністр праці та соціальних питань Губертус Гайль.
«Світлофорна» коаліція у коаліційній угоді затвердила
одноразове підвищення мінімальної зарплати на 12 євро.
Підвищення набуде чинності на початку жовтня.
Для багатьох, тобто для шести мільйонів людей у Німеччині,
особливо для жінок та працівників зі Східної Німеччини,
це підвищення є, можливо, одним з найбільших у їхньому
житті.
Сьогодні під час голосування Союз CDU/CSU утримався.
Його члени говорять про занадто
складні бюрократичні перешкоди,
хоча під час останньої виборчої кампанії
вони самі апелювали підвищенням
мінімальної заробітної плати.
Ми не проти підвищення на 12 євро,
на цьому ми вкотре наголошуємо.
Але ми проти визнання соціальних
партнерів недієздатними.
Підвищення мінімальної
зарплати - це рішення політичних діячів,
а не компетентної комісії з мінімальної заробітної плати.
У берлінського салоні вірять, що він зможе
залишатися конкурентоспроможним,
та переконані, що підвищення було вкрай необхідним.
Добре, що є мінімальна зарплата.
Без неї було б важко жити, неможливо.
Збільшення мінімальної зарплати на
12 євро відбувається в часи критичного зростання цін.
70 років британська королева перебуває на престолі.
Важлива подія з масштабними урочистостями.
Сьогодні в Лондоні відбулася церковна служба подяки.
Це стало своєрідним місцем зустрічі
відомих особистостей.
Не змогла прибути тільки королева.
Через погане самопочуття Єлизавета II
змушена пропустити захід.
Репортаж Діани Ціммерман.
Натовп марно чекав свою королеву.
У палаці пояснили, що, на жаль,
релігійна монархиня не зможе приєднатися
до богослужіння в соборі Святого Павла.
Вчорашній день, мабуть,
був надто виснажливим для 96-річної королеви.
Та все ж багато інших знаменитостей були присутні
на урочистостях.
Загал освистав контроверсійного прем'єр-міністра.
А от появи Гаррі та Меган чекали з нетерпінням,
вперше за довгий час вони прибули до Лондона,
відколи склали повноваження активних членів
королівської родини.
Зрештою від імені своєї матері
прибув ﻿майбутній король - принц Чарльз.
Чи можуть британці уявити,
що одного дня він зійде на престол?
Я думаю, монархія йде нам на користь.
Я переконана, що до Чарльза ми також звикнемо.
Звісно, я буду і надалі підтримувати монархію.
Але мушу визнати, що я фанатка королеви
і не надто велика шанувальниця монархії.
Темами богослужіння стали почуття обов'язку
та витривалість королеви.
Архієпископ Йоркський порівняв 70-річне правління
Єлизавети II з дуже довгою їздою верхи
та передав привітання до Віндзорського замку,
звідки, ймовірно, королева дивилася трансляцію.
Нам шкода, що Ви сьогодні не змогли бути тут.
Але ми радіємо, що Ви й надалі міцно «сидите у сідлі».
Що ж, не достатньо міцно, щоб змогти взяти участь
в усіх урочистостях на її честь.
Британці все ж сповідаються,
що в неділю
королева ще привітає їх з балкона.
А зараз про страшний сон кожного спортсмена.
Відкритий чемпіонат Франції.
Норберте, у півфіналі Александр Зверєв
у поєдинку проти Рафаеля Надаля отримав травму
і змушений був здатися.
Так, на жаль.
Олімпійський чемпіон вів запеклу боротьбу проти іспанця.
Лише подекуди Надалю вдавалося реалізовувати
успішні маневри.
Та невдале приземлення
наприкінці другої партії змінило все.
Трагічнішого завершення першого півфіналу
у Парижі годі й уявити.
Рівна боротьба, рахунок 6:6 і тут Александр Зверєв
підвертає праву ногу.
Його жахливий крик від болю
дає зрозуміти, що травма справді дуже серйозна.
Нам було важко бачити його сльози.
Я можу побажати йому тільки найкращого.
До нещасного випадку гравці показали велику
майстерність.
У першій партії перемога Надаля була близькою.
А ця подача неабияк вразила фанів.
У неділю у фіналі Відкритого чемпіонату у Франції
Надаль буде боротися за свій 14-й титул.
А Александр Зверєв поки може відкласти свої мрії.
Десятикратний чемпіон НДР.
У 2001 році СК «Магдебург» святкував
свій перший чемпіонат Німеччини.
А минулої ночі, 21 рік потому, історія повторилася.
СК «Магдебург» переміг у матчі
проти «Балінген-Вайльштетена»
з рахунком 31:26 і передчасно
забезпечив собі титул.
Після фінального свистка аплодисменти лунали
як в залі, так і поза ним.
Це визначна подія не тільки для одного міста,
але й для цілого регіону.
Завтра відбудеться матч Ліги націй.
У Болоньї збірна Німеччини зіграє проти
чемпіонів Європи - Італії.
Прибудуть всі 25 гравців, окрім нападника ФК«Боруссії»
Марка Ройса.
Чотири дні команда тренувалася,
доводили техніку до ідеального автоматизму.
Ганс Флік з нетерпінням
чекає на матч в Італії.
Загалом я впевнений, що всі дуже вмотивовані.
Як у першій грі, так і зараз в Лізі націй.
Ми налаштовані на найкращий результат.
І я вірю,
що цей матч буде успішним для нас.
Щодо складу команди не передбачається несподіванок.
Однак Флік залишив імена гравців в таємниці.
У мене все.
Дякую, Норберте.
Наразі гідрометцентр попереджає
про сильні грози в Баварії.
Більше про погоду розповість Катя Горнефер.
А ми запрошуємо вас до перегляду «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом о 22:00.
До побачення.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні опівдні над Баден-Вюртембергом
пройшли перші грози.
Вдень ці повітряні маси рухалися з Альп.
Зливи та грози не вщухатимуть усю ніч.
І далі попрямують на Схід,
а вже завтра вранці залишать територію Німеччини.
Натомість на Півночі Німеччини вночі
буде сухо та ясно.
А також - найхолодніше.
Температура - від 12 до 6°С.
Попри грози та зливи, на Півдні Німеччини тепліше -
від 16 до 13°С.
Завтра на Півночі, на узбережжі
очікується 16-20°C.
На решті територій термометр покаже 21-27°С.
На Верхньому Рейні температура повітря підніметься
до +29°С.
Це найтепліший день Трійці.
Переважно світитиме сонце.
Тільки подекуди: на території Середньогірʼя,
у напрямку Східної Баварії,
на захід від Рейну та на гірському масиві Шварцвальд -
очікуються вдень незначні зливи або грози.
На Зелену неділю
із заходу насуватиметься негода,
яка майже повністю огорне Німеччину.
І тільки північніше від річки
Ельби буде сухо.
А тоді поступово погода налагодиться.
Гарного вечора.